This video is brought to you by
Skillshare,
a wise crack jared in the pale flesh.
Again,
today we've got an episode for you about
Pokemon go,
urban exploration and some dead French
guy,
fusion,
pokemon go temporarily gripped the world
like an epidemic.
The augmented reality mobile game,
just days after it's released,
was installed in five percent of all
android devices and even surpassed
tinder in downloads.
To say that we were gripped by Pocomania
all over again is an understatement.
The media and now wisecrack just
wouldn't shut up about it.
Pokemon goers have discovered dead
bodies been lured into being robbed,
crash their cars,
and even trolled the Westboro Baptist
church.
At the same time,
plenty of people were less than an
hammered by Pokemongo filmmaker Oliver
Stone decried the games ramp in data
collection as a new form of surveillance
capitalism.
He also warned that the idea of people
running around to catch imaginary
monsters as dictated by a giant
corporation can go by another name,
totalitarianism,
so it's Pokemongo a nightmare.
Confluence of phone addiction and
corporate surveillance.
Maybe let's find out.
Welcome to this wise crack addition on
the philosophy of pokemon go,
and for once no spoilers ahead at its
heart,
pokemon go is a game about walking you
saunter to a pokey stop dash towards a
raid stampede towards a dragonite
trespass into a neighbor's yard,
stumble into a crime scene,
and so on,
and while walking may seem as
philosophically unimportant as an Adam
Sandler movie,
you'd be surprised,
but before we can understand how pokemon
go radically changes how we interact
with physical spaces,
we need a little history of walking.
Unsurprisingly,
walking played a prominent role in
society until the rise of the
automobile,
besides getting people from point a to
point b,
walking was a sort of sport and
aristocratic circles as Frederic Gros
writes in his book,
a philosophy of walking well to do.
Men and women would stroll around in
fancy clothes,
occasionally striking a pose to woo
potential suitors.
It was kind of like the physical
manifestation of rich people.
Selfies on Instagram for others,
walking was a holy matter every year.
Scores of people would undergo a
pilgrimage to various sanctified sites.
Meanwhile,
philosophers like Friedrich Nietzsche
saw walking as an invaluable part of the
philosophical process today are walking
and movement in general still serves a
social function,
though it's a little more pragmatic.
Now,
our morning commute running to the
grocery store,
picking up sunny Jim from soccer
practice.
Most of these comings and goings are
programmed into our daily lives.
We move from place to place,
generally unaware of our surroundings
and never venture far from our planned
route all to fulfill our societal
obligations as gross writes this kind of
rushing around is always in the service
of doing something and never to just be
walking according to gross is in its
purest form about doing nothing which
allows us to rediscover the simple joy
of existing I kind of childlike
wonderment with the world surrounding
us.
Some might argue that pokemongo
according to this logic,
follows the always doing something logic
of our time frantically running from
pokestop to pokey.
Stop chasing down legendary rates and
battling.
Kim's isn't exactly the kind of
exploration grosses,
writing about.
We'll tackle that in just a second,
but first let's talk about space.
Every street building and open space
carries with it and assumed social code
wouldn't behave in an office building
the same way you would at a concert.
You don't play football and freeway and
many would say it's important to wear
your black sabbath tee shirt to church,
but those social codes change with time
and culture.
Public bathing used to be a thing.
Bars used to be a place to find a date
and rivers used to be a fine place for
you to drop,
trow and do your business.
Pokemon go and the technology it uses
might change everything by radically
recoding.
This space that we live in the game has
literally mapped onto reality and
entirely new set of social codes,
parks for hiking now,
more like a sweet place to battle of
Mutu churches for worship now,
pokey balls for days and it crowd all
running in the same direction could be a
Zombie apocalypse,
but it could also be an unknown museums
to memorialize the millions of people
slaughtered more like,
okay,
seriously,
don't play pokemon go and the Holocaust
museum in short,
Pokemongo disrupts how we perceive
space.
There's a common fear with pokemon go,
should we really trust a massive
corporation with such intimate knowledge
of where we're going and how we're
getting there?
Is it a little scary that a company can
so artfully tell us where to go?
Niantic has integrated sponsored pokey
stops and starbucks,
for instance,
was more than happy to oblige.
The idea is you get to buy a Pumpkin
Spice Latte once you've decided to take
a break from catching mythical monsters
so far,
aside from some sponsored pokey sops,
that intake has taken the high road
organizing things like beach cleanups
for Earth Day,
but that doesn't mean it can't go
downhill fairly quickly.
What if you could pay niantic a couple
million dollars to have a rare pokemon
spawn at your political rally or worse,
your friends Improv show for French
philosopher,
Guy Debord.
Modern capitalism has neatly organized
time and physical space.
Where we are,
where we're going and when we're getting
there is a function of the totalizing
control.
The economy plays in our lives.
We traveled through life,
mesmerized by our commodity filled
environment.
We go to work to make money to a leisure
activity,
to spend money,
go home,
go to sleep,
and repeat with a sort of systemic
pressure to do this in a more and more
productive way.
Work harder,
enjoy more sleepless.
You get the idea for some pokemon go,
easily fits this dystopic narrative.
Yesterday,
we were mesmerized by billboards and
where they told us to go probably to
some tgi Friday's today.
We're mesmerized by our phone screens
and where they tell us to go.
What's missing from all this is chance,
randomness and discovery,
but before you think we're being overly
paranoid,
edge Laura's those who decry pokemon go
as the harbinger of some dystopic,
augmented reality are only half right,
Pokemongo as Edwin Montoya's rewrites in
the Hong Kong.
Review of books resembles deary.
A revolutionary strategy proposed by
debord to combat the entrenched and
alienated ways in which we move through
cities do receive,
which is French,
for drifting means abandoning the
preprogrammed way in which we interact
with cities.
By performing a sort of experiment in
space,
wandering around aimlessly,
debord encourages people to walk around,
be drawn in by their surroundings,
interrogate them,
and to give themselves up to randomness,
and that's kind of what pokemon go does.
Players venture to locations they never
would have dreamed of going to namely
outside,
but if you're anything like me,
you've discovered new neighborhoods,
new landmarks,
and even this one's a shocker.
Made friends in the myspace.
Pokemon go is combating the kind of
social alienation that our culture
actively promotes.
Well,
most games have you glued to a screen
with headphones on.
Pokemon go encourages you to explore and
make new friends.
After the raid system was introduced,
you could battle boss level pokemon for
a limited time with friends or
strangers.
They also recently rolled out trading,
adding new ways to meet new people.
Psychologists,
we've been noticed that the game was
helping their patients with anxiety and
depression by getting them to get out of
the house and socialize in this way,
pokemon go actively recode's the space
around us in a positive way.
It might not be exactly the kind of
revolutionary walking that debord
envision or the useless kind of walking
gross writes about,
but it's also better than the
alternative that are tech obsessed
society offers us.
Who knows?
Maybe pokemon go is a gateway drug for
hiking and social interaction.
What do you think wise crack is pokemon
go's society,
savior or a harbinger of disciple times
to come?
Or is it just a game about animals and
balls?
Let us know what to think in the
comments and as always,
thanks for watching.
Hey wisecrack.
It's Alec Polka Master.
Extraordinary reading.
This episode was a ton of fun,
but we came across one big problem.
Jared went on a much deserved vacation,
so in service of Jarrod's mental health,
a bunch of us in the office have to do
his job for the next few weeks and for
those unaware,
he does everything.
He edit scripts,
he directs,
he reviews cuts.
Luckily skillshare has us covered.
They have classes on video editing with
Adobe Premiere 2018 for beginners and
they have diy cinematography so he can
keep up that Gerald livable quality,
but even if you're not trying to run
wise crack or build your own youtube
channel,
they have a of classes.
Maybe you want to make the next pokemon
go.
Skillshare has crash course in three D
game design.
Join the millions of students are
already learning on skillshare with a
special offer just for wisecrack fans.
Get two months of skill share for free
to sign up.
Visit the link in the description or
head to skl that ssh slash wise crack 13
and get unlimited access to over 20,000
classes today.
And as always,
thanks for watching.